and let's come back to your point about
a positive vision for the future and why
conservatives uh will struggle with that
I think one of the reasons is that
inevitably young people do need to rebel
against something and conservative
instinctively want to suppress all
Rebellion because they want to avoid
change and that's why as someone who's
kind of some I call myself politically
non-binary that's why I'm excited about
talking about this political Vision uh
and positive not political or positive
vision of the future because I think
that's what's needed and I don't think
the anti-work position which a lot of us
have had to engage in for some time uh
is going to be the answer because you
have to have something that people buy
into and it can't be normative in the
way that conservatives often want it to
be you must do this that's not going to
work with young people they don't want
that what they want is something that
allows them to channel their Rebellion
into something heroic and productive as
you said which is why I think showing
young people the way way out of wokeness
through what I talked about on the
speech and what you and I just talked
about which is work hard build and
create that is going to be the way and
um I think you you probably know my
friend Melissa Chen she tweeted
something about this years ago that I
thought it was so spot-on she said
um you cannot remake remain woke if you
build anything whether that's a business
whether that's muscle whether that's a
family and that's why I challenge these
kids the dogs for the union and and the
audience who were watching of course to
build and create things because the
moment you start you suddenly find out
that hey just whining about stuff
doesn't work and when you get down to
the business of doing things turns out
there's a reason that things are the way
they are there's a reason things don't
work quite the way you'd like them to
because reality suddenly comes into
conflict with ideology and so that's why
I think it's so important to give kids
and young people a path to doing things
because it's only when you're doing
things that you start to realize the
limitations and the the you know I'm a
huge fan of Thomas Saul and this is one
of his things that he always says that
there are no Solutions only trade-offs
and you only learn this as a young
person by the experience of doing stuff
because when you're young you come at
the world and you go well the world
isn't perfect I must perfect the world
and no one's explained to you and you
probably didn't listen if they tried to
explain to you uh the the fact is the
world is not perfectable the world will
always be imperfect and all you can do
is Tinker at the edges to try and
improve it so one of the things I've
noticed on my tour
one of the things that's perplexed me
let's say is that I wrote these books
that are full of rules and you might
think that that would turn people off
for the reasons that you just described
young people being turned off by let's
call it conservative moralizing and
that's a kind of finger shaking you
should and should is
if you were doing your duty it's
something like that yes and look you
should do your duty and but you can also
understand why young people would chafe
against that because
well why should they be certain that
doing their Duty in that in exactly the
same manner that duplicates the past is
the best pathway forward because
sometimes it clearly isn't and there are
inadequacies of the past that need to be
rectified so the conservatives stumble
in relationship to establishing uh uh
bridge to Young People by
being moralizing and the more
Evangelical types of say fundamental
Christians fall into the same problem
now one of the things I've noticed and
this has been very very cool and I've
really tested this in hundreds of venues
is
I usually sometime in one of my lectures
in my lectures talk about the
relationship the necessity of finding
meaning
as a as the antithesis of suffering
let's say because
the quest for meaning becomes most
compelling when you're simultaneously
suffering or someone you love is
suffering that's when the
that's when the arrow Finds Its Mark
let's say
and I
walk people through a thought exercise I
suppose is well
what do you have
when you're suffering that's going to
sustain you and you might say well
you have the work that you're still
capable of doing and the fruits of your
labor that might offer you some security
you have whatever creative Enterprises
you might be able to engage in that
still contain the shadow of meaning at
least then you have your intimate
relationship and the person who might be
caring for you while you're in Dreadful
condition and you have your family and
your friends and that's really what you
have and then on the abstract end you
know maybe you have Beauty and truth and
Justice and you know the noble ideals
but then you might ask yourself well
how do you
how do you have the
the Armament of work and creative
Endeavor and friends and family and the
answer to that is that's in precise
proportion to the amount of
responsibility you've taken for
developing those relationships and those
abilities that's right and so there's a
clear pathway between the voluntary
adoption of responsibility and the
meaning that will sustain you through
suffering and that's a much better
enticement to participation for young
people than a kind of finger wagging
top-down morality which is you must
behave this way you know or you're no
good and even though I as I said there's
some truth in that it's not an
Invitational Vision no
and I I think that there's a way to
summarize that very neatly Jordan which
is what I know would work for me which
is to say there are things that you want
what are they
and if you want those things this is
what you need to do you don't have to do
it I'm not saying you must do it I'm not
your dad but if you want to achieve
these outcomes that you care about then
you're gonna have to put in the work and
I'm not telling you which outcomes you
should pursue necessarily but the way to
get there isn't going to be to glue
yourself to a road to stop an ambulance
get into a hospital which is what these
Extinction Rebellion people do here in
the UK and I think that once people
young people are on that path we don't
get to control the art and the culture
that they're going to create that is
their path and that is their Duty and
that is their job to do uh but if if
they are doing it from a place of
constructive taking on responsibility as
you say putting in the effort building
and creating things for the future then
I think that is part of the vision for
them because as you say I think we live
in a society particularly now
you know I'm not a religious person but
it's clear to me that uh with the death
of God you end up in a position where a
lot of people lack meaning and of course
you've got all sorts of other economic
disincentives for people to have meaning
it's harder to start a family uh people
are deferring it until a later point I
myself you know I just turned 40 and we
had our first child only a year ago less
than a year ago so a lot of young people
are in that position now and it's having
that experience that changes you uh and
makes you more responsible it forces you
to take on responsibility it also forces
you to look at the world in a different
way so uh that I think is part of the
vision uh and uh you know talking about
family is difficult because again you
get to the normative position where it's
like you must have children uh which is
not what I'm saying at all but again I
think if you start from the incentive
point of view my experience of life is
that people respond first and foremost
to the incentives that are in front of
them and if you want if you like meaning
if you don't know what to do with your
life then finding an intimate partner
and having a family is going to be a big
part of that in addition to meaningful
work etc